you and Nick have your guests come and
visit you and you get into bed with them
yeah so it's the three of you in bed
Andy I know that you participated in
this I did in their actual bed we were
all fully clothed but all aroused it was
the sexual tension was so thick you I
mean it was like walking through pudding
walking through a sexual pudding oh
absolutely
okay all right your kind is there we
have a picture of this sex fest and you
could tell you guys that's that's
unfortunate
my god yeah so long that's what I like
to say yeah those are it looks look at
those feet again those are pods
those are Andy those are Lunar Module
pop yeah when I go to the beach people
are like there was a bear here
well did you now do you find it's called
in bed with Nick and Megan yeah so we're
actually in our bed but we it hasn't
started yet it starts in December but
you've started getting people to do it
I'm I always said that I wanted to do it
yeah well I didn't know there was a
podcast I just heard you guys wanted me
to be in bed with you let's go but yeah
I would love to do that okay it would be
really fun yeah you seem thrilled yeah
yeah all right we'll get to that
well now you were at the top of our list
I think you're out of the country when
we were trying to get you to do it
before no maybe I fled the country